і ризографі коли комплексні поки що
допомогу ложки годинник
столітті тпр переживаючи україна when включаючи
на 40 конкретних адаптованих для
україни заходь у 13 ключових на прям
як ми то допомогу 53 матір'ю формули
секторі без піку та оборони україни нині
прикладом на активно пройти йому натра
привіт закону
про засідки національні bespeco
концепцію реформи СБУ
адже ти буває разом з нашими
партнерами з дурень ніж місій з ми з
протягуємо і вся концепція буду їхня хвиля
на найвищому рівні восени
а по зодіаку нові волонтерів та офіцери
for міністерство оборони
запущена дуже багато проекті мацали
бджоли у мовницького служба active
йдіть прологу esto que me dan
обслуговування нову уніформу
реформа харчування ти теж позитивні
зради та ми їхнього валіуму вона буніна шкода
на системну реформу у
ми з реджі мосина там ще в Україні
можна будуть допомогти
системно на стратегічному рівні більше
системна реформа дасть Україні змогу
бути на стандарти нато чехова на
класні правильно
you which
так на це спілкування кіл у двох в офісах
натомість в Україні так ось уже на проти
чи
і дайте простий низах udev буквально все
адже починаючи самі ти уельсі у 2014
уроки
scream того плутаєте патент на душу
важливий документ добуду прописано
програму день на доступний рік швидкості
вмивалася квітні кому безпосередньо заходив
покликаю частиною на сам перед маневром
це ви школам і
проте тепер ми всі цифри для так йому та
наступна уроку україна зможеш у середи
тис на стратегічних реформах рахунок
запустить і процес євроатлантичної
інтеграції України
щоб же через рік країни нато побачили
як україна реально спостерігалося а дано
тлумачиш